samir is seven years old
he is weak and suffering from a skin
disease
his family is from pakistan's sindh
province one of the regions worst
affected by the flooding they were
trapped in their village chardadkat for
one week in august before they found
temporary shelter more than 300
kilometers away in a roadside camp
one of samia's brothers did not survive
his father too grief-stricken to speak
on camera
shelters like these have become a
mainstay
many people have similar ailments
the floods have not only taken our homes
but also we are faced with acute
diseases where everyone is suffering the
doctors just visit the camps but we
don't get proper treatment it's very
painful
some have found assistance in charity
charity-run camps but even they are
facing severe shortages
almost all of us including children the
elderly and women got ill because we
don't get clean drinking water and the
government is not providing proper food
kids have diarrhea and may die if they
don't get proper medical care
the world health organization is
concerned about the spread of cholera
and local authorities say bacteria and
parasites are thriving in the stagnant
water causing an outbreak of waterborne
diseases
the number of patients from the
flood-affected areas are 550 000 gastro
650 000 skin related 185 000 are malaria
cases and almost 12 000 are dengue
related cases so it's a huge challenge
these camps have become homes and
clinics but they lack basic food clean
water and medicine
stretching aid and healthcare workers to
their limits
laura about a manly al jazeera